romain Delville nous a rejoint sur le
plateau pour une page de sport en
football on en sait un peu plus sur le
32e de finale de la Coupe de France qui
va opposer laocc au racine Club de
Strasbourg romain et oui on une fois
passé l'excitation he du tirage au sort
il y a gros d'organisation comme on dit
dans le chinoné pour la voine olympique
chinonciné parce que oui il y a eu de
l'excitation lundi soir au moment de
tirer le RC Strasbourg pensionnaire de
Ligue 1 faut savoir que l'an dernier au
même stade de la la compétition la OCC
avait tiré vierszon ça fait un peu moins
rêver et que les vierzonnais finalement
les avaient sortis de la coupe alors le
Racing Club de Strasbourg c'est un club
qui est actuellement 10e de la Ligue 1
c'est pas n'importe quel club he non
plus dans l'histoire de notre
championnat en France c'est un club
historique du foot français on estime
que c'est un peu le le Marseille de
l'Est il a connu une descente aux enfers
dans les années 2010 ou plutôt il a
choisi de redevenir amateur pour
remonter dans l'élite là à la rentrée de
septembre 2023 le club a été racheté par
un consortium américain ça l'a fait
rentrer dans la galaxie du club de
Chelsea vous l'avez annoncé hier soir
fustine le match aura lieu samedi 6
janvier au stade de la Vallée du Cher à
18h les dirigeants du club armorimall
l'entraîneur ont visité les
infrastructures hier avec la Jean sport
de tour Eric Thomas la location du stade
va coûter 3000 € au club alors c'est un
grand Airbnb vous le voyez Airbnb en
tout de 12
12899 € hier soir cé réunion
extraordinaire de la OCC ce qu'il en est
ressorti c'est qu'il faudra une centaine
de bénévoles pour tenir les CIN buvettes
faire office de plaer d'agence d'accueil
et cetera alors la OCC veut garder un
esprit familial et va devoir faire appel
à des assauts locals pour compléter les
effectifs l'idée c'est de vendre les
places à des prixabordables aussi au
moment où je vous parle la fourchette
c'est entre 10 € les places découvertes
peut-être sous la pluie et 20 € pour la
tribune présidentielle je vous rappelle
qu'en Coupe de France la recette des des
entrées est partagée entre les deux
clubs il paraît que ce match c'est aussi
une histoire de retrouvaill entre les
entraîneurs des deux équipes et ouais
c'est là qu'intervient un peu le moment
copain d'avant on est au tout début des
années 90 Armand rimbaau Patrick virant
la quinzaine là Patrick vira bien sûr à
gauche Armand rimbaau à droite le
premerier vient du loircher le second
arrive de Dreux ils intègrent le le
centre de formation du Tour FC mainbaau
que vous voyez là il dev deviendra
gardien mythique du TFC jusqu'à
atteindre la Ligue 2 Patrick vira milieu
de terrain légendaire sera champion du
monde 98 champion d'Europe en 2000 avec
l'équipe de France séquence nostalgie on
a vu Armand rimbaau cette semaine pour
qu'il nous parle de ses années où il
partageait la même chambrée
ouais on était dans la on était dans la
même chambre au centre de formation qui
à l'époque était juaposé à la vallée du
Cher après on a déménagé quand le CTRO
est est sorti de terre et on avait la
fameuse chambre 20 au bout du couloir
que que beaucoup de beaucoup de
pensionnaires connaissent d'anciens
pensionnaires c'était Jam sabourau à
l'époque le recruteur de tour qui nous
avait qui nous avait ramené la même
époque et et voilà après on n' pas eu le
le même parcours parce que Patrick il a
fait une carrière de gigantesque et
voilà c'est on était je pense que tous
les gens qui l'ont connu à tour sont
très heureux de la carrière qu'il a
qu'il a pu faire parce que c'est CIT
quelqu'un de bien alors revenons au
match et revenons à la Coupe de France
est-ce que la OCC a une chance face au
Racing Club de Strasbourg Faustine sur
le papier 4 division s par les deux
équipes donc a priori la OCC n'a aucune
chance sauf que la Coupe de France de
football c'est la compétition des
exploits c'est le moment pour les clubs
amateurs de vivre des épopées il y a eu
calé il y a eu carque fou qui ont marqué
l'histoire de la Coupe et puis sur le
plan financier en recevant une équipe de
Ligue 1 la OCC est sûr de gagner bon on
l'espère en tout cas merci Romain pour
ses explications